I'm not gonna lie I opted to skip the
Tom Cruise on the mummy but I did read
watch the brendan fraiser one and I
still like it
so the mummy has come out too not good
reviews and a very mixed box-office I'm
going to get to that in a little bit
I'll pick into that a little bit more
but largely what I want to talk about
here is what's going to happen to the
dark universe that is attempting to be
built that that Universal is is trying
to make with all of this and I think
adding is very much going to be kind of
up in the air but let's start let's
start with some numbers so the film
opened in second place which is never
great in especially considering that it
was the major release of the weekend it
opened in second place behind Wonder
Woman which is already big which is in
its second weekend so when you take
second place to a film that's in second
weekend that's really not good the movie
came in in around thirty thirty two
million domestic and that is that is not
impressive I mean there's pretty much no
way that breaks 100 million total
domestic box-office now international is
faring much better it's something like
160 million for the International now
that is the biggest international box
office opening for a Tom Cruise film by
contrast the domestic opening for the
mummy is lower than it was for the
Scorpion King the spinoff from the last
mummy series so yeah not great now and
again like I said domestic of very
unlikely to break 100 million this
thing's not going to have legs this
thing has a cinema score of a b-minus I
haven't talked about cinema score before
I've talked about Rotten Tomatoes and I
I've talked about things like that what
CinemaScore is is it takes a company
that takes surveys of audiences as they
have coming out of movie and they rate
it on an a to have scale now the way
that they tend to work really anything
that isn't in the a range is iffy at
best because honestly the general
audience tested audiences tend to rate
movies much more favorably than critics
do so while critics may be averaging you
know by god seven and a half on though
which you know would be like I see if
you were to translate that in America
into a letter grade you know most
audiences will be giving it an A - a B+
this thing getting a b-minus and as a
rule of thumb anything that gets to a C
which this is just barely doing better
than that's generally considered to be a
fail as far as how CinemaScore tends to
equate the grade that audiences are
giving these things so it's probably not
going to have legs either because it's
not connecting with audiences now will
the international box office be enough
to keep this thing going I would say
probably for one more movie because to
make the comparison to say Sony with
their amazing spider-man series the
first amazing spider-man did okay it
underperformed some expectations but it
really was all going to come down to
because the sequel takes the criticisms
of the concerns that people have and fix
them and do it better amazing spider-man
2 failed to do that pretty much
everything that didn't quite work in the
first amazing spider-man they made worse
and yeah people didn't really care for
that under performance only had to pump
the brakes on their entire spider-man
thing Universal might be looking down
the barrel of slightly similar situation
in terms of just you know they've got
enough things in motion I think the the
Frankenstein one is probably the one
that's furthest along because it's got a
director in Bill Condon it's already got
Javier Bardem on as the Franklin Monster
I think there's a pretty good chance we
still get that one but unless that one
is a knock out of the park more or less
a homerun I think we're probably not
going to see too much in terms of this
interconnected universe we may still see
some of these films because I
Universal Universal is kind of lacking
in a major franchise momentum right now
they're not really play they're not
really able to play the games that that
Fox and Disney and Warner Brothers are
playing in terms of major tentpole
franchise Universal doesn't really have
much going and they were hoping dark
universe was going to be their entry
into that and it's really not looking
good now they still have you know well I
say they have the rights most of these
stories and most of these creatures on
that they have been planning the
Invisible Man they've announced pawns
back from Notre Dame Frankenstein I
mentioned Wolfman family they offered
these are public domain characters but
they have the always choose a specific
Universal interpretation and version of
these characters Christian is a black
and Creature from the Black Lagoon is
uniquely theirs because that was the
movie wasn't based off Pacifica adapted
material but they may lose the impetus
to try and interconnect these films so
the whole pro Digium thing with Russell
Crowe is dr. Jekyll who was looking to
be their version of Nick Fury and shield
and all that I would not be shocked if
that takes a backburner place in
Frankenstein and then goes completely
out the window and I think fundamentally
and again I will confess or not have you
seen The Mummy movie but from the
reviews I've read the fact that it is at
least as interested in world building as
it is telling the story if not more so
is one of the major complaints people
seem to have about it and I think they
made largely the same mistake that
Warner Brothers did although they made
it sooner I would say that when with
Warner Brothers and I'll keep my DC EU
criticisms to it of them I'm promising
it's for a point of comparison at least
Warner Brothers they made a standalone
Superman film and Man of Steel it wasn't
until Batman V Superman that they got
something that was buried in
world-building and you didn't really
stand up as a great narrative in and of
itself so at least they did one film
that was a solid standalone film before
they went into that mess
Universal they couldn't even get that
lesson two it immediately and it seems
like befits every everyone who wants to
make a cinematic universe is pretty much
playing catch-up to Marvel Marvel made
the playbook on this but no one's
actually following Marvel's playbook
they want to jump ahead to the Avengers
but they see they either forget or they
willfully ignore the fact that Marvel
built up to that and what's more in the
film's leading up to the Avengers the
world-building stuff was tiny Easter
eggs or almost completely restricted to
either the background or the post-credit
stuff think about it the only hint that
there was going to be a Marvel Cinematic
Universe with a post-credits singer at
the end of Ironman and then in the films
that followed it was just the existence
of shields it was like it was Coulson
showing up it was these tiny things they
took up maybe one scene and they weren't
massive exposition dump
they were just things that connected the
world but very little actual screen time
was spent on those prior to the Avengers
which truly brought everything together
but instead these other Studios very
obviously want to get to the big
Avengers money first because I mean the
other Marvel films were successful but
Avengers was worth it blew into the big
money and they all want that now and
they think they can fast-track it but
you can't it doesn't work because
they're sacrificing actually telling a
story for the sake of doing faster world
building and it just doesn't work so in
terms of whether or not the
International can save this I I don't
think we're looking at a Transformers
situation where the International alone
makes it worth the money so while this
is a very good opening for Tom Cruise
traditionally Tom Cruise still opens big
in the US and then the International is
just icing he that's gone on this one
and so the international box office on
this and you're probably looking at a
bit more of a Pacific Rim situation
where once all the money is calculating
they go yeah we'll take one more crack
at that because I mean you think about
Pacific Rim they really drag their feet
before announcing and putting into
motion the sequel
and it does seem like the amount of
money that that personal maid was really
riding blind isn't worth our costs to do
this again now in the case of Universal
I think it is more worth their cost to
do it again but I would also not be
surprised if the if these projects take
a big budget cut because the mummy the
mummy was kind of expensive for what it
was because they they took a lot I mean
they tried to be taken more seriously
but they were taking more queues in
terms of the scale and the scope of
everything from the 90s as the 99 mummy
movie and its sequel then from the
original universal monster which was a
very low-key thing so I think we might
be seeing when they get to their next
home which again I expect to be
Frankenstein or Bride of Frankenstein it
seems to be going back and forth which
ones actually being made but it's
something Frankenstein related I expect
the budget is going to be cut on that
and it's going to become lower key but
the thing is honestly I don't I don't
know how much leg work is being done by
these studios into whether or not anyone
wants these cinematic universes and I
think Sony in a lot of ways is making
the same mistake with a spider-man
Cinematic Universe I mean that being
said I think you ask most people would
you like more spider-man related movie
they would say yes but I think that's
probably because they don't understand
that what Sony is planning to do is to
have them completely disconnected from
the MCU probably not even having time
all of us but oh man
appearing but I rant about that before
I'll get off that I don't think there
was really anybody out there clamoring
for a universal monster Cinematic
Universe and I understand there's a
legacy and there's a heritage that
because they effectively were the
original cinematic universe but also
let's keep in mind it's easier to say
that but you think about it by the time
they were mashing those monsters up it
it quickly became a joke I mean they
went from Frankenstein Meets The Wolfman
to Frank him to Abbott and Costello Meet
Frankenstein and that happened pretty
quick the whole idea of these mashing
them up was not it was not like a
prestige let's get back to that it
became a joke even at the
ah so the whole idea of reviving that
and taking it dead serious just it
strikes me is really weird and I'd say
that like I'm not opposed to bringing
these characters back but he'll tell us
tell their story or better tell a new
story with them because honestly most of
these stories audiences know whether
they've seen the original universal
monster versions of these characters or
not
people know these stories already that's
why even though it didn't work and it
wasn't great I have more respect for
what they were trying to do with Dracula
untold which was originally supposed to
be the first start to their shared
monster cinematic universe but at least
that was trying to do something
different with the Dracula legend rather
than just telling it's the same story of
Dracula yet again now the mummy as far
as that goes could have been different
because the mummy is is a fairly generic
set up thing gets awakened there's a
curse that's really all you need beyond
that you can go big in scoping and go
small scope you've got a lot more wiggle
room the actual beats of the story
aren't as fixed but rather than use that
as a as an opportunity to actually tell
a story they talked it just to do a
crap-ton of world-building so they blew
that but if they bring this Frankenstein
out and they go okay listen even if they
think okay let's let's get more focused
let's tell Frankenstein if they just
tell Frankenstein is anybody going to
care one of the last time anybody cared
about a Frankenstein movie a straight-up
one I mean I remember the one from the
90s the one with Robert De Niro and
Kenneth Branagh which was okay but even
at the time I don't think anybody cared
and I don't think it was Appetite to see
Frankenstein to get has gotten any
better because honestly Universal made
the iconic version way way back when
they did the original same with Dracula
for that matter and to be fair I think
that's one of the reasons the mummy
could have been a better place to start
because the actual original mummy movie
is not quite as iconic the concept of
the mummy is that actual movie not so
much but Dracula Frankenstein all you
can really do is tell the stories then
again or do
completely different which I don't think
that well because they tried with
Dracula untold and it didn't work I just
feel bad for universal right now because
I feel like they're they're grasping at
straws
and they latched on to this because it
was something they already had this was
in their vault and in their real house
of stuff to be able to do they didn't
have to license a property they didn't
have to do anything like that but it's I
don't see this working out for them I
think the only one that has any
potential that I'd be interested in
would be The Creature from the Black
Lagoon because that is really only those
previous movies then while the look is
iconic and the look is become saturated
with pop culture the creature itself
hasn't been done to death the way pretty
much all the rest of this has so again
summing up and the wake of the mummy I
expect we'll get universals Frankenstein
thing and if that is dead on arrival
these things are either going to go away
completely or at the very least they're
not going to bother interconnecting them
and they're going to be done on much
smaller budgets so those are my thoughts
on the fallout from The Mummy landing
with a thud in the u.s. at the very
least so what are your thoughts about
all of this does it make you sad that
this dark universe is probably not going
to happen our lease is probably going to
get a massive reconfiguring or you know
are you happy did this bum you out that
it was going to happen do you not care
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter right
council of geeks give a listen to the
council geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]